hey hey and welcome this is the been in
Shapiro show got a lot coming up for you
this a little bit later on in the hour
we'll be taking your calls at eight five
five two three six thirty two twenty
eight that is eight five five two three
six a thirty two twenty eight the news
at this hour is all coronavirus all the
time and the reason for that is because
there's a lot of breaking news on
coronavirus apparently the World Health
Organization has now suggested that
coronavirus is indeed a global pandemic
that of course is not supremely
surprising I mean we know that this is
broken out in countries all over the
globe we have reported cases of corona
virus in the United States that surpass
a thousand in virtually every state in
the Union West Virginia has no report so
I guess that ascend for us all to move
to West Virginia to be safe from
coronavirus with all of that said it is
unclear exactly what the path of this
pandemic is going to be we know that
there is a briefing among Republicans on
the hill there was suggestion that
somewhere between 75 and 150 million
Americans could eventually get
coronavirus if the death rates are
indeed ten times higher than the flu
that would mean hundreds of thousands of
Americans die of korenev iris which of
course would be horrifying in the
extreme and it would speak to Chinese
irresponsibility in shutting down all
news and distribution of information
about coronavirus in the early stages
you know it's amazing China's trying to
claim credit now for having quashed
coronavirus in their own country it's
like yeah well guys you wouldn't have
had to quash it anywhere else nobody
else would have a problem if you just
mentioned that this is a problem in the
first place I mean the fact that the
Chinese government shut down all
information meant the people were
traveling from Wuhan all over the world
and that means that we now have
outbreaks everywhere from Israel to
Italy I mean it's just incredible that
the Chinese government think that they
can get away with all of this in the
face of evidence that they covered all
of it up the world's health organization
according to CNBC has now declared to
cover 19 a global pandemic on Wednesday
the new the novel coronavirus
has rapidly spread to more than a
hundred and twenty-one thousand people
from Asia the Middle East Europe and the
United States in the past two weeks the
number of cases outside China has
increased 13 fold the number of affected
countries is tripled according to w-h-o
director-general dr. tad rose at Hunnam
Gabri asus and said that in a press
conference he said in the days and weeks
ahead we expect to see the numbers climb
at the number of deaths the number of
affected countries climb even higher he
says we're deeply concerned both by the
alarming levels of spread and severity
and by the alarming levels of an action
we have rung the alarm bell
loud and clear this is the cases in
China and South Korea have significantly
declined
he says 81 countries don't have any
confirmed cases 57 countries have 10 or
fewer cases he says all countries can
still change the course of this pandemic
some countries are struggling with lack
of capacity some countries are
struggling with lack of resources some
countries are struggling with lack of
resolve well one of the problems here of
course is that testing kits are not
available in many countries at this
points we actually don't know how many
cases are out there also again once the
once this is out there the question of
how do you restrict its spread becomes
very very difficult when they say that
the number of cases inside China is
declining that's true because China has
initiated lockdown what happens when
trying to ends the lockdown
I mean it's trying to just keep people
locked down for four months how exactly
does that work maybe they do even if
they do if there are still people with
cases out there can't it just spread
additionally among the public have you
frozen it or have you ended it is really
the question the virus is slowing in
China where it originated in December
but it's picking up pace in other parts
of the world Italy has the most cases
outside of China we're roughly 10,000
infections Iran has 9,000 infections
South Korea has 7800 infections the
Health Minister in Britain apparently
has come down with coronavirus Tedrow
said this is the first time a corona
virus has caused a pandemic dr. Mike
Ryan executive director of the WH OS
health emergencies program said health
officials take the characterization very
seriously adding we understand the
implication of the word Ryan says we
have hospitals who need our support we
have people who need out of care we need
to focus on getting our frontline health
workers equipment supplies and training
and they need to do a good job the
organization raised its risk assessment
level on the virus to its highest level
of alert last month but had been
hesitant to declare it a pandemic he
says unless we're convinced it's
uncontrollable why I call it a pandemic
while I guess now they think it's
uncontrollable so here's how does this
thing end good piece by William Wan over
at the Washington Post talked to
biologists he says they're basically
three scenarios one health officials
control coronavirus through strict
public health measures this is when
severe acute respiratory syndrome SARS
hit Asia in 2002 is pretty scary a
fatality rate of about 10%
no drugs shown to be effective against
it the current coronavirus has a
fatality rate that's been estimated
ranging from less than
one two three point four percent within
months Syrus was brought under control
the most part stamped out by
international cooperation as well as
isolation quarantine and contact tracing
that would be an ideal outcome but Syrus
had more severe symptoms people went to
the hospital pretty quickly cases of
coronavirus are obviously harder to
catch and isolate okay that's best case
scenarios we somehow isolate this thing
and shut it down
second coronavirus is less developed
countries things get worse before they
get better
one of the grim lessons from Ebola in
West Africa says the Washington Post is
how an epidemic can grow when it hits
countries with weak health
infrastructures this is why the w-h-o
and others have been preparing countries
in sub-saharan Africa for coronavirus
even though a few cases so far have been
reported there compared to kimono my
wrists Ebola was less contagious
transmitted mainly by bodily fluids the
death rate was significantly higher
Ebola is still infected twenty eight
thousand people and caused 11,000 deaths
in Africa w-h-o leaders have been urging
countries to prepare on Friday the
organization raised its assessment of
coronavirus to the highest level and
then there's the third possibility which
is that the corona virus spreads so
widely and then becomes basically just a
fact of life this is what happened to
swine flu it eventually hit 11 to 21
percent of the global population h1n1
turned out to be milder than initially
feared it caused little more than runny
noses and costs in most people now it's
basically seen as part of the seasonal
flu early estimates for the fatality
rate for h1n1 we're much higher than the
roughly point zero one two point zero
three percent it turned out to be still
CDC estimates that h1n1 killed about
twelve thousand people in the US during
that first year period and infected 61
million people and caused two hundred
seventy five thousand hospitalizations
it's difficult to ascertain you know how
accurate those numbers are given the
fact that how do you distinguish one
type of flu from the other h1n1 is a
good parallel because it had a lower
fatality rate than SARS Ramirez but it
was deadlier because of how infectious
and widespread it became so how exactly
does this one line up well it's deadlier
than h1n1 by these statistics available
right now and it also spreads like h1n1
although maybe not quite as widely this
means that buying time is the name of
the game because we have to develop a
vaccine if we're able to develop a
vaccine
and obviously this thing will will be
tamped down no one knows whether the
seasonality of the flu is going to
affect this thing typically flu goes
down in warmer seasons but it is unclear
which direction this moves all of this
is suitably frightening obviously it
becomes even more frightening when you
realize that the federal government
botched the initial response that is not
Trump's fault that is the fault of a
giant federal bureaucracy